democratic organ governor kate brown
facing backlash for pushing racial
equality over getting a quality
education after she quietly signed a new
bill that gets rid of math reading and
writing requirements in order for high
school students to graduate the
governor's office says it will help
students of color but she is being
accused of dumbing down schools to
appease far left liberals so dana i
think this is a tragedy for everybody
because you're lowering the standards
rather than thinking kids could rise to
the challenge to me it's child abuse and
as a taxpayer i'm mad because the return
on investment is not good enough
how much money
both state and well i don't live in
oregon so i don't pay state taxes there
but the federal government also kicks in
think of how much money went for covent
relief they spent 20 percent of this
money the rest of us just floating out
there so we are basically paying kids to
not actually meet standards
and or i'm sorry paying these school
districts to do that and i think our
national competitiveness is at great
risk that means our national security is
at risk and what kind of life are you
subjecting these people to and their
parents you think that people want to
have a better life than their parents
this is the american dream you dumb down
standards this badly and you will get
exactly what you pay for and i don't
want to pay for it anymore i'm tired of
it well and will it's not necessarily
the parents who are asking for the
standards to be lowered it's these
activists who pressure the mayor and not
just an organ in virginia fairfax
virginia they just did this too by
getting rid of ap english and ap classes
because they say it was unfair you're a
dad you think your kids should have
standards for excellence absolutely but
be clear this is driven out of racial
politics so this is not only a tragedy
and not only child abuse this is flat
out racist this is the idea that black
and brown children cannot satisfy
universal standards so we must lower
them and they suggest that's somehow
white supremacy it's like the
african-american museum in washington dc
putting out that document a year ago
that said punctuality hard work and
objective thought are caricatures of
white supremacy no these are the path to
success and for you to suggest that
black and brown kids cannot live up to
those standards is flat out racist one
more analogy this is going to the doctor
and them saying we're not going to test
you because you could be sick the con
the patient is still sick regardless of
whether or not your tests come back
these kids still graduate they will
still be ignorant they will not be able
to satisfy those standards and life will
punish them for that no matter you
putting these tests aside yeah jessica
i don't like it i think
there has to be a better way and i know
that we kind of say this every block
right as some terrible thing happens
with a police officer being killed or an
unarmed black person being killed or
what's going on in these schools and
it's extremely frustrating as someone
who does believe in the cause of
affirmative action and think that
children who have grown up in homes
black white brown whatever it is where
they have faced systemic challenges and
need a helping hand deserve that that we
can't figure out a better way and when i
was reading about this it said you know
we moved to we're gonna move to the
system for a year so that we can like
look under the hood you have to be able
to look under the hood at the same time
that kids are still going to be taught
at an appropriate level so that they can
qualify to go on with their lives
whether that means going to an
apprenticeship going to college going to
junior college getting a job whatever it
might be um i i don't like it but greg
aren't isn't the left locking students
particularly students of color into
these prisons and giving them a lifelong
sentence because
parents in the inner city are trying to
get the kids into charter schools so
they can actually achieve these things
to maybe get a scholarship to college
this kind of education ensures that none
of them will even qualify well it
guarantees that the basically the first
step into a competitive life
you're already in the negative it's like
you're not everybody else is going to be
better off than you are and it's an
assessment on this idea of equity which
is not about the freedom to achieve but
to install a ceiling to achievement it's
just like socialism everywhere it's a
crushing
limit from above that says all of you
will be stupid together if you if you
guys can't do math and you guys can't do
math but you can do math no no one's
doing any math we could teach you guys
math but we just prefer all of you just
be ignorant of math but there are things
you can do you can there's a guy on
twitter corey
corey angelus deangelis deangelis if
you've been on twitter he's led the
charge on the new trend of allowing
parents to take their education dollars
everywhere
elsewhere about the public schools and
that's a really good thing school choice
obviously and and and we should be
thinking about improving uh remote
learning i think that's the way to go
man it's what it's what peloton did to
the gym dana you haven't i'm sorry i
just wanted to add one other thing so
the democrats dropped a bill yesterday
to have 3.5 trillion dollars in spending
and what two of the things that are
included in there are free pre-k for
everybody and free community college let
me tell you right now
there's no if people cannot pass a basic
standard test to get out of high school
i do not want to pay for free community
college
that there should at least be some
standards and if this monstrosity passes
the republicans at least ought to insist
on those standards that's a great point
people would people would love their tax
dollars to go to a super tough school
that makes everybody smarter for free
exactly
why why we're spending more money per
student than anywhere in the like i
don't know in the world and we're not
doing it federal taxes and property
taxes that you're locked into so it's
almost like it's not even about
education they just want to take hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else